pateando un balón o pintando más de 50
menores buscan encontrar una nueva vida
después de ser reclutados por el estado
islámico a temprana edad expuestos a la
violencia y al extremismo ideológico
estos menores que se encuentran en el
centro de rehabilitación orquesh
experimentan las secuelas de criarse en
entornos sumamente conflictivos lo que
les provoca problemas en la
socialización y en el desarrollo
cognitivo
no queremos que los niños estén
permanentemente en estos centros pero
los esfuerzos diplomáticos son lentos
por eso pensamos que Establecer un nuevo
centro es estratégicamente mejor hoy en
día Cuando hablamos de rehabilitación de
niños no hablamos solo de 100 o 200
niños hay muchos más que necesitan
rehabilitación
los padres de algunos de ellos proceden
de países como Estados Unidos Reino
Unido o Francia y aunque por normas del
derecho internacional estas naciones
tienen responsabilidad de aceptar a los
niños dentro de sus fronteras los
trámites de retorno son obstaculizados
por controversias de política interna la
meta de este centro es trabajar con los
menores para que en un futuro puedan
volver a casa
el objetivo a largo plazo de nuestro
proyecto es preparar a los niños para
que puedan aceptar a otros e integrarse
en sus sociedades cuando sean
repatriados
el reclutamiento infantil dentro de los
conflictos armados está prohibido por la
normatividad internacional un marco
legal constantemente transgredido por
organizaciones extremistas según
Naciones Unidas los niños son reclutados
entre otras cosas con motivos
propagandísticos que genera rían
visibilidad mundial Además de que la
manipulación a los menores es más
efectiva en Siria la esperanza por
devolverle su niñez a miles es latente